YOU KNOW, A LOT OF THE TIMES ON
THIS PROGRAM WE'RE ALWAYS
TALKING ABOUT THE PROBLEMS
IN OUR SOCIETY.
BUT OUR SOCIETY HAS MUCH TO
CELEBRATE!
>> EVERYBODY'S TALKING ABOUT
DAD BODS.
>> GUYS WHO LOOK LIKE THEY GO TO
THE GYM BUT THEY ALSO MAYBE
ENJOY A LITTLE PIZZA,
A LITTLE BEER.
>> ELIZABETH AND I FIND IT
REALLY ATTRACTIVE.
>> LEONARDO DICAPRIO, JASON
SEGEL AND SETH ROGEN HAVE ALL
BEEN CALLED DAD BODS.
>> UNDEFINED ABS AND MAYBE EVEN
A LITTLE BIT OF FLAB
ARE ACTUALLY IN.
>> WOMEN ADMITTING
NORMAL-LOOKING GUYS ARE THE SEXY
ONES.
>> Jon: YEAH!
IT'S LIKE CHRISTMAS CAME EARLY
THIS YEAR FOR DUDES!
CAUSE EVERYWHERE YOU LOOK
THERE'S JOLLY FAT MEN.
FOR MORE ON THE NEW LOOK THAT'S
DRIVING WOMEN'S CRAZY,
WE'RE JOINED BY SENIOR WOMEN'S
ISSUES CORRESPONDENT,
KRISTEN SCHAAL!
KRISTEN!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> HELLO! WELL, THANKS, JON!
AND WHAT A GREAT DAY FOR MEN!
IT'S TIME SOCIETY FINALLY
ACCEPTED THAT A MAN'S BODY
CHANGES WHEN HE HAS KIDS!
HE SPENDS NINE MONTHS EATING TOO
MUCH BECAUSE HIS PREGNANT WIFE
IS STRESSING HIM OUT AND THEN
THERE'S A SCREAMING BABY AT
HOME, HE'S GOT TO GET OUT FOR
PIZZA AND BEER AS MUCH AS HE
CAN.
IT'S JUST BIOLOGY, JON.
>> Jon: BUT YOU KNOW, A LOT OF
THOSE GUYS WE JUST HEARD ABOUT
THEY'RE NOT EVEN DADS.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE A DAD TO
HAVE A DAD BOD, YOU JUST HAVE TO
BE REALLY LAZY.
AND WOMEN ARE LINING UP AT THE
DAD BOD BUFFET WHICH IS GREAT
NEWS BECAUSE NOW YOU DON'T HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT MAGAZINES LIKE,
THIS SHOVING AN IMPOSSIBLE BODY
IMAGE DOWN YOUR THROAT, LIKE
THIS CHISELED TRIANGLE THING,
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT, LIKE THE
BORDER LINE BETWEEN WHERE
THE CHEST ENDS AND THE FUN
BEGINS?
(LAUGHTER)
YOU KNOW WHAT, LET'S JUST FORGET
ABOUT THESE NAMES BECAUSE IT IS
GONE!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
THANK YOU!
THAT FELT EMPOWERING, JON.
>> Jon: WOW.
>> HERE YOU TRY IT!
>> Jon: NO, NO, THAT'S OKAY --
>> RIP THIS GUY UP!
>> Jon: OKAY. THERE WE GO.
ABSOLUTELY. HERE WE GO.
>> YEAH!
YEAH!
GET RID OF IT!
GOOD JOB, JON. JUST PUT ALL YOUR
--
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
>> WELL, YOU KNOW WHO REALLY
LOVES THIS DAD BOD TREND?
>> Jon: WHO?
>> GUYS LIKE YOU WHO GET MOST OF
THEIR EXERCISE BY TURNING FROM
CAMERA ONE TO CAMERA THREE.
>> AS A 40-SOMETHING-YEAR-OLD
DAD I FIND THIS NOTION
PROFOUNDLY REASSURING.
>> SHOW US YOUR DAD BODY.
>> I WISH I COULD.
>> I'M GONNA GO AND GET A BEER
AND PIZZA AFTER THE SHOW.
>> I THINK WOMEN THINK YOU'RE
SORT OF NUTS IF YOU'VE GOT LIKE
THIS SIX PACK.
>> I'M IN A DAD BOD SANDWICH
RIGHT HERE!
(LAUGHTER)
>> THEY'RE ALL HAVING A REALLY
GOOD BELLY LAUGH --
WELL, THE GUYS ARE.
IF THAT WOMAN HAD A BELLY AT
ALL, THEY WOULD NOT LET HER ON
THAT SHOW.
>> Jon: WELL, I DON'T KNOW.
KRISTEN, I MEAN,
(APPLAUSE)
MAYBE IT'S A GOOD THING.
MAYBE DAD BOD, DAD BOD IS JUST
THE BEGINNING AND IT OPENS THE
DOOR TO CELEBRATING THE MOM BOD.
>> OH, SWEET, SWEET JON...
WE'RE ALREADY OBSESSED WITH MOM
BODS, OR AT LEAST HOW FAST MOMS
CAN GET RID OF THEM.
>> THERE'S NEW BREED OF MOM ON
THE PLAYGROUND, DUBBED MOM
SHELLS, A HYBRID OF MOMMIES AND
BOMB SHELLS.
>> THAT'S 11 MONTHS AFTER GIVING
BIRTH.
>> SHE LOOKS AMAZING.
>> SHE HAD A BABY SEVEN MONTHS
AGO.
>> SHE HAS A FIVE-MONTH-OLD.
>> THREE MONTHS AFTER HAVING
BABY.
>> LOOKING IMPRESSIVELY SVELTE.
>> PERFECT.
>> AMAZING.
>> INCREDIBLE.
>> JUST WEEKS AFTER GIVING
BIRTH --
>> LOOK AT THAT FIGURE TOO.
SHE'S JUST HAD A BABY!
>> THEY'RE NOT REAL PEOPLE,
THEY'RE CELEBRITIES.
BEYONCE, SCARLETT JOHANSSON,
J. LO, MICHELLE DUGGAR.
>> Jon: MICHELLE DUGGAR?
FROM THE REALITY SHOW WITH THE
19 KIDS?
>> YEAH. THAT'S HOW HOT SHE
IS.
HER HUSBAND IS NEVER NOT
(BLEEP) HER.
WHY DO YOU THINK SHE HAS TO HIDE
HER BODY UNDER THAT SISTER
WIFE DRESS TO STOP TEMPTING
THE REST OF US!
>> Jon: WHY IS THERE SO MUCH
PRESSURE, THOUGH, ON WOMEN TO BE
SKINNY? YOU KNOW IT HASN'T
ALWAYS BEEN THAT WAY.
LOOK A AT THE RUBENESQUE WOMEN
IN THOSE OLDER PAINTINGS BY --
>> OH RIGHT, PICASSO?
TALK ABOUT IMPOSSIBLE BODY
STANDARDS, I SPENT YEARS TRYING
TO GET MY NOSE ON THE SIDE OF MY
FACE.
ADMIT IT, JON, WOMEN WILL NEVER
BE ABLE TO RELAX ABOUT
THEIR BODIES THE WAY THAT MEN
CAN.
>> Jon: WELL, IT'S TOO BAD
BECAUSE IT FEELS GREAT TO
BE ABLE TO, YOU KNOW, TO NOT
THINK ABOUT IT, THE OLD,
FEEL GOOD IN THE OLD DAD BOD OF
MINE.
>> YOU EARNED IT, DADDYO, ALL
THAT NOT WORKING OUT, FOCUSING
ON OTHER THINGS BESIDE YOUR
BODY, YOU KNOW WHAT, WHY
DON'T YOU STAND UP AND GIVE
THE AUDIENCE A LITTLE TREAT?
SHOW THEM WHAT
A MOSTLY ADEQUATE PHYSIQUE LOOKS
LIKE.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> YEAH!
COME ON! YEAH!
GIVE THEM A TWIRL.
WORK WHAT YOUR MAMA GAVE YOU
THAT YOU DIDN'T TAKE CARE OF FOR
50 YEARS!
I DON'T HAVE TO ASK IF FRIES
GO WITH THAT SHAKE BECAUSE THEY
OBVIOUSLY DID.
SHOW OFF HOW YOUR LOOKS ARE NOT
WHAT SOCIETY VALUES MOST IN YOU!
AH! LOOKING GOOD.
>> Jon: OH WAIT. WAIT, HOLD ON.
>> YEAH, THERE YOU GO!
>> Jon: I'M STARTING TO FEEL
IT!
>> THERE IT IS.
>> Jon: OH, YEAH. I'M STARTING
TO FEEL IT.
>> YEAH. KEEP POSING, KEEP
POSING.
>> Jon: I'M STARTING TO FEEL
IT NOW, UH-HUH, OH, YEAH!
HERE COMES THE TWERK! I'M GONNA
TWERK!
00:05:22,088 --> 00:00:00,000
I'M GONNA -- I'M GONNA --